Documentaries come in all shapes and sizes
– from the political urgency of Michael
Moore’s Fahrenheit 911,
to Werner Herzog’s meditative Cave of Forgotten
Dreams.
Some are funny, like Errol Morris’ 1997
film Fast, Cheap, and Out of Control.
And others are earnest and striking, like
13th, Ava DuVernay’s examination of mass
incarceration.
The best ones use many of the same cinematic
and storytelling techniques as fiction films
to explore their characters and themes, and
take audiences on an emotional journey.
And Otto Bell’s 2015 film The Eagle Huntress
fits that bill.
It tells a nonfiction story using traditional
cinematic techniques and ultra-modern equipment,
all without sacrificing the heart of the tale.
[Intro Music Plays]
Director Otto Bell found his inspiration in
a few still images published by the BBC in
2014.
They showed a young Kazakh girl in traditional
dress with an enormous eagle hoisted on her
arm, or launching into flight.
Within a year, Bell had packed some gear,
enlisted a few crew members, and traveled
to one of the most remote locations in the
world: deep in the heart of Mongolia.
And what he found there was an extraordinary
character and an underdog story.
Now, during Crash Course Film History and
Production, we talked a lot about film as
an illusion of reality.
Filmmakers use the tools of cinema – things
like shots, cuts, sound, and narrative structure
– to trick us into believing what we’re
seeing.
The whole point is to make an audience feel
something, whether it’s fear, joy, or heartbreak.
A director wants us to experience the story
with the characters.
Documentaries are no different.
They’re illusions of reality too.
I mean, sure, the characters they depict are
by and large real people.
And the stories actually happened.
But documentaries use the same basic techniques
as fiction films.
And the best ones use those cinematic tricks
in good faith.
They might collapse time or choose out-of-sequence
reaction shots, but only in ways that remain
true to the spirit, theme, or subject of the
story.
In The Eagle Huntress, those film techniques
are beautifully harnessed to tell the story
of Aisholpan Nurgaiv, a 13-year-old Kazakh
girl living in Mongolia who dreams of becoming
an eagle huntress.
Eagle hunters have both a practical and cultural
significance to Aisholpan’s nomadic people.
Eagles are used to hunt game for fur and meat.
But they’re also used to compete in festivals
and competitions, where eagle hunters test
their horseback, hunting, and eagle-calling
skills.
The film opens with sweeping aerial shots
of the mountains and plains of Mongolia.
These could just as easily be the opening
shots of a Lord of the Rings movie, they’re
so epic.
And in the first scene, we see an older man
riding a horse to a far-off mountaintop.
He’s there to release his eagle back into
the wild after seven years as his hunting
companion, as per tradition.
We sense this man’s deep connection to the
bird, as he offers it a final meal and then
rides off, never to see it again.
From there, we meet our protagonist, Aisholpan,
who lives with her parents and siblings in
a yurt-like tent.
We learn that she’s always idolized her
father and grandfather, who are both prize-winning
eagle hunters.
She wants to follow in their eagle hunting footsteps.
Something relatively few women are doing.
And just like that, we’re on her side.
The film has given us a compelling protagonist
with a clear goal and obstacles.
We’re pulling for her, and her father is
pulling for her, too.
As he trains her in the techniques of eagle
hunting, he tells us, “I don’t want to
let her down.”
The film then introduces us to a group of
older, conservative, male eagle hunters.
None of them believe a girl should be allowed
to learn how to eagle hunt.
It’s a man’s job.
But they’ve never met Aisholpan!
She’s tenacious, hard-working, and – we’re
told – naturally gifted.
She’s also a 13-year-old girl, who takes
care of her brother and sister at her boarding
school, paints her nails, and giggles with
her friends.
In one of the film’s most thrilling sequences,
we see Aisholpan and her father track an eagle
to its nest, high on a rocky cliff.
There they discover two eaglets.
Her father ties a rope around her waist,
and she clambers down the cliff face to capture
her very own eagle.
From there, the training ramps up, until it’s
time for Aisholpan to compete in her first
eagle festival, which takes place in Ölgii,
Mongolia.
She’s up against men three, four, or even
five times her age, with years of experience
and competition titles.
And still, in event after event, Aisholpan
holds her own.
Her eagle even sets a speed record, flying
from high atop a hill to her arm in less than
five seconds.
Spoiler alert: against all odds, she wins
first place in the festival, raising her trophy
overhead in triumph, surrounded by a cheering
crowd.
It’s a powerful moment.
But it’s not enough for the chorus of elder
eagle hunters.
They’re dismissive, and some even change
course and claim that her youth and gender
gave her an edge.
Lastly, the documentary follows Aisholpan and her father as they pack up and ride off into
the snowy wilderness, hunting for a fox.
They work together, father and daughter, for
days.
And after several missteps and some seriously
deep snow, Aisholpan and her eagle finally
spot, chase, and bring down a wild fox.
In the film’s final moments, her father straps
the fox to her saddle and they ride off for
home, not just as father and daughter, but
as a pair of true eagle hunters.
The Eagle Huntress is a simple movie.
And that’s part of its power.
The film distills its themes beautifully and
presents such a winning and offhandedly-heroic
protagonist, that it feels easy.
But... it wasn’t.
Like, at all.
We don’t judge the quality of a film based
on how hard it was to make, but director Otto
Bell and his skeleton crew deserve special
mention for capturing the images and sounds
that bring this story to life.
First, they traveled to a bitterly cold, remote
region of Mongolia, and relied on very modern
technology to tell this story about a longstanding
tradition.
Relatively lightweight digital cameras allowed
them to travel and work in these far-flung
locations.
Drones allowed the filmmakers to create tracking
shots, crane shots, and those glorious opening
aerials without the expense of dolly tracks,
helicopters, and actual cranes.
Mini Go-Pro cameras strapped to Aisholpan
gave us a first-hand view of her climb down
to the eagle’s nest and the first interaction
she has with her eagle.
Those same cameras, attached to the eagles
themselves, provided us a glimpse of their
point of view as they soared through the sky.
Second, they integrated themselves into the
lives of Aisholpan, her family, her friends,
and the older eagle hunters.
Aisholpan was understandably shy at first.
It took time and patience to get her to open
up and speak conversationally in front of
the cameras.
And third, they did it all while trying to
remain respectful of her culture.
Documentaries aim to depict real people in
real situations, but they’re still illusions
of that reality.
So these films bear a different kind of ethical
burden than fiction films.
And no one in The Eagle Huntress comes off
mocked by the film or filmmakers – not even
the old men who look down on Aisholpan.
They’re presented as wrong-headed and misguided,
for sure.
But it’s also clear that they’re grappling
with a changing world.
This brings us to one way to look at this
kind of film: as an ethnographic study of
a longstanding culture within the modern age.
The roots of this documentary film tradition
trace all the way back to one of the first
feature documentary films,
Robert J. Flaherty’s Nanook of the North
made in 1922.
Nanook took audiences deep into the frigid
Canadian arctic to follow the struggles of
an Inuk man and his family.
That film, however, has been roundly criticized
for distorting or even fabricating events
to make the Inuk culture seem more exotic
and out of step with the contemporary world.
In real life, the main character wasn’t
named Nanook, didn’t have a wife, and hunted
with rifles, not spears as the film shows.
By all accounts, The Eagle Huntress is a more
culturally respectful and honest film.
Rather than exoticize Aisholpan, the filmmakers
seem more interested in presenting her real
life.
By doing that, it actually makes this remote
culture feel familiar.
While we do see her in traditional dress and
riding horseback, we see her wearing denim
jeans and modern coats.
Her family rides motorbikes and trucks, as
well as horses.
And one shot even shows us a portable solar
panel that the family packs up with them when
they travel.
The juxtaposition of ancient tradition and
modern life is driven home when Aisholpan
and her father travel to Ölgii, the largest
town for a hundred miles.
A series of shots follow them riding horses
across vast empty landscapes, eagles perched
on their arms, dressed in traditional furs.
Then we see them riding into town, along roads,
next to cars, and past stores.
It’s as if they’ve ridden out of the past,
right into the present.
Which, by some interpretation, is how Aisholpan
functions within her culture.
She’s taking on the traditional practice
of eagle hunting, and doing it as a contemporary
woman.
Now, The Eagle Huntress has been criticized
for distorting Kazakh and Mongolian culture,
so it’s not a perfect ethnographic study.
Stanford historian Adrienne Mayor suggests
that this documentary may have focused too
much on making Aisholpan’s story seem unique
and filled with adversity.
Mayor points out that there were many female
eagle hunters throughout history, and that
there are several active ones today.
Women like Makpal Abdrazakova, whose story
has been reported on since 2011.
And even though the head-shaking elders add
to the drama and conflict of the film, Mayor
and others say that Mongolia isn’t a misogynistic
culture.
Even though Western audiences and filmmakers
might assume that of nomadic societies or
other countries.
Aisholpan’s parents’ constant support
of her and her passion for eagle hunting is
genuine, but may not be as unusual as the
documentary implies.
Other eagle hunters and people of Mongolian
communities have said that women were never
discouraged from this tradition.
And there’s evidence that women have consistently
had important roles and opportunities in these
societies.
So this could be a case where the director
had a story in mind because of what he filmed
and his assumptions, rather than what he researched.
And it led to a slightly askew portrait of
the truth.
Still, The Eagle Huntress works as a traditional
hero’s journey, and an examination of an
long-lived society in an increasingly modern
world.
Sometimes the simplest stories pack the biggest
punch.
It’s a beautifully made documentary about
a young girl who embraces her culture, works
to master an old art, overcomes her obstacles,
and – through hard work and fearlessness
– claims her place in the world.
And next time, we’ll make our way to Miami
for a look at the intimate, heartrending coming-of-age
drama and Best Picture Oscar winner Moonlight.
Crash Course Film Criticism is produced in
association with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check
out a playlist of their latest amazing shows,
like The Art Assignment, Physics Girl, and
Reactions.
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Crash Course Studio
with the help of these nice people and our
amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.